uh we're gonna start off evolves a game
where you play as like you got one
monster you got four Hunters they're all
controlled by people and they try to
kill each other we're gonna start off
teaming up that's right let's let's be
friends I'm gonna join your game so the
monster has already spawned in monster
has like a 20 to 30 second Head Start uh
you already see the indicator right
there the monster scared the birds so
that's one of the ways you can track
where the monster's at of course when
Daisy's in the game when a Maggie is
being played that means that we're gonna
pretty much follow Daisy and here she is
right here uh getting getting started
also they're glowing blue Footprints
that's that means he's close that's the
way to trap the monster or track the
monster rather and so we're basically
gonna try to follow Daisy here Daisy has
an exclamation mark over her head I
believe
it's a really good sign that
and so there's also other wildlife in
here and other Wildlife some of them are
Elite wildlife and they give you perks
so check it out there's a perk over here
you might want to come grab this I will
try uh watch out there's some jerks
hanging out there but we've already got
a teammate like really pursuing far
ahead you generally want to stay
together it is a Fool's errands to go
off on your own yeah and try to kill the
monster on your own yes you look cool
you will die it is so important to stay
with your team
um if you guys can see right now what
I'm doing is I'm putting Harpoon traps
down
um
I can do that throughout the map because
if the monster while it's eating trying
to evolve and staying away from us if it
gets caught one of those Harpoon traps
we'll know exactly where it is and it'll
get stuck for a little bit giving us
ample time to catch up to it so while we
don't see the Monster it's actually
important for me to just spread these
out throughout the map I get five uh at
any one time once I max out it'll take
away my last one that I uh the one that
I put down first basically so I'll put
them down sparingly uh in places that I
think the monster might cross as I just
Traverse the map hoping that I can take
it Monster is here I think all right so
Daisy's pointing
I don't know where's daisies I'm just
looking at you Daisy is on tracks she's
got you can notice right above Daisy's
head
it's got a little uh yellow sign on it
and it's got a footprint on it that
means that Daisy is tracking his
Footprints if it's an exclamation mark
that means it's close Daisy has his full
scent and she's on the move so those are
a few ways that you can know kind of
where Daisy's at there are times when
you shouldn't follow Daisy that's true
uh she's really good if you're lost and
you don't know where you're going right
now I'm actually not sure where the
monster is well so here's the thing
about Daisy is she is like
a little confused right over here you
have to stay kind of close to her as the
Trapper She's Not Gonna Go Far Away from
you no she stays near me and then she
tracks as I'm near her so now that we
don't know where the monster is we'll
we'll kind of go to Daisy for some kind
of guide where are you going girl where
you going girl
um Daisy is not the fastest
oh we found him
Daisy found him
oh yep
uh so you can also there's if you click
the right stick you'll be able to put
those little waypoints down uh those are
a great way to just quickly say go this
way the monster's over here and if you
tag the monster you'll see oh just
missed him take it down yeah you can
easily take down the Trapper if you miss
he's right I can see his footprints
let's hurry up
get this guy oh hello
so I'm the medic I need to now back up
tracking the monster is like a really
great thing to do as a medic because
it'll slow the monster down and also put
that outline around it so everyone can
see
um
and then also you can tell you're on the
track because it uh those waypoints that
I'm putting down just by clicking the
right stick turn red when you have put
it directly on the monster so now we're
on the trail we can follow these tracks
and find the Monster uh speed is
imperative right now we don't want to
lose him uh if you use your jet pack
you're more you're going to get more
distance than on your feet so it you'll
see uh my jet pack
is on the right here it's a little blue
yeah that's your jetpack meter on the
right as long as it's full use it you're
much faster when you use it than
anything else do you think we should go
down there no that the Croc is down
there I just we'll just stick with where
Daisy wants to go oh Daisy went into the
Croc not all the way down so yeah the
Croc is this oh yeah
The Croc is this really big monster that
sits at the bottom over here he is
dangerous trying to give you guys a huge
asset to the Goliath this thing right
here
it's like really gnarly I probably
shouldn't have shot it and pissed it off
that was a bad idea
from it now
uh okay yeah it's gonna go away now
it's fine we're just gonna keep
following Daisy away from the Tyrant uh
so there are a ton of other animals in
the area and those animals don't just
serve to feed act as fodder for Goliath
you know we've seen the birds fly I see
some dead meat over here we've seen the
birds fly up in the air uh and now he
has evolved that that's where the
monster is so
the monsters evolved that's the thing
about the course of the match there it
is don't get stronger at all so remember
to clickier stick
oh is it I thought I saw him did we get
them I hope so does it tell you it
doesn't say that actually oh yeah we got
him there he is
sucka
all right I got the trunk in so now
we're just gonna start doing as much
damage as we can uh and staying healed
and cranking oh God so right now I'm
putting down Harpoon traps everywhere I
don't care about my other ones this
guy's gotta go down give you some heels
here
see that he's harpooned multiple times
our poons don't do that much damage it's
more about Annoying the monster and
containing him so that everyone else can
do damage again my job isn't to do a
[__] ton of damage my job is to oh yeah
that Harpoon just saved me oh no we're
in trouble he was like Leaf smashing are
you guys oh
we got a
we got an additional monster on the
field right now oh my God where are you
all right so yeah we had another monster
in play there for a second uh the
monster is now gonna try to get away I
got him at the track so we can maybe do
a little more damage
tagged him with the sniper rifle good
job uh which uh the sniper rifle will
punch a hole in the armor so that
whenever anyone shoots it it will do
more damage uh but for now
we are in Pursuit and that was a good
engagement we had no one incapacitated
yep uh we have all good health
situations well we have decent Health
situations going on you guys with me we
have a second yeah we're right behind
you
have a second to catch up on healing as
we pursue if we're going down into this
area watch out for the Tyrant because
that thing will grab you and you he he
might know this this might be
the tactic to lure us in
and you can heal from pretty far away if
you see this sort of heel beam situation
Dom oh get out of it get out of there
Markov move it move it oh geez that was
close
so this guy's
going off on his own a little bit
peanuts where he's going see that
kind of following this guy a little bit
yeah
don't be a hero
he is still coming but at this point
Daisy's more maybe following you
um but still has the footprint sort of I
am following Footprints it looks like
curse knew what he was doing
um kind of just assumed that he knew and
the thing is is Daisy is not typically
the fastest route to the monster a
really good way to go about it is to
look at where Daisy is running and use
signs like birds and dead carcasses and
Forge your own path and try to cut him
off in between uh it's you actually
probably can't catch up with the monster
easily by yourself so it is yeah you
want to try to you know because this is
just a big big huge Arena area and you
want to try to you know he must be
around in like a loose group but also
Fork off to the side all right the
monster scared birds over there all
right walk off to the side sort of do
cutting off you know just to try to get
eyes on uh where the monster's at so I'm
attempted to come through here but
that's kind of a big it's dangerous
that's where curse is uh curse is going
off by himself it's a very dangerous
move
I would not recommend let's see if we uh
what we encounter around the back of
this generator are about around the back
of this facility
where are you guys at all right you're
with me I'm following Daisy we're about
to meet up with purse over here
who is and then we can you can like try
to jet pack up if you run out of Jetpack
just keep holding a and facing the the
rock that you're trying to climb and you
will climb it slowly by hand okay we
found the Goliath it's over here we'll
try to see if I can drink
I'm coming oh yeah there he is I got him
I got him
oh yeah
oh you're in trouble now buddy
all right the Goliath is down that way
I think he kind of went went around and
climbed up all right he should still be
contained he's trying to hide
where are you you're the son of a [__]
doing a really good job hiding oh yeah
right up there
definitely playing the stealthy
monster all right I got him with the
trunk
he's avoiding damage a lot we gotta get
you gotta Stick it to this yeah I gotta
I gotta get him in a harpoon right now
uh she knows the arena is gonna go he's
trying to make an escape here
you drug him
God he's fast come back here where's my
drink he's so fast so yeah evasion is a
real strong tactic as a monster because
that gives you time to regenerate your
Shields by eating and also
evolved yeah because you wanted every
time you evolve as a monster and we'll
get a Monster Match in a little bit
every time he evolves the monster you
get more abilities uh and you get
stronger abilities oh don't fall down
into the Croc area
come on climb up this thing oh crap
I do not want to be down here with the
cross he scared birds over here but I
don't want to go in without the medic
the medic is so important to the teams
success that uh a good monster will know
to actually take out the medic first
which is why
Chris is
trying to stay away yeah because he has
to stay alive
um
like I said uh we actually cannot
function without a medic so monsters
Goliath will often
go after uh the medic first take out the
medic then take out the rest the medic
is the first and the most likely and you
know if you get trapped in the dome and
you take out the trapper
uh you will where is Curse catch up
buddy uh if you take out the Trapper
then the Dome will come down and you'll
be able to escape so if you're in a bad
situation you can uh yeah we're all sort
of rendezvousing again all right Daisy
is going the opposite direction I see
footprints
he has evolved into stage three which
means we can continue to we should
attack him or do you want to go round up
here all right because now once you get
to stage three there's another win
condition that comes into play for the
monster and that's this power relay that
you now see activated
uh they can the monster can roll up in
there and
cause some serious problems where do you
want to have the fight
I mean we should just go hang out by
this power relay
um I am outside what you'll see now
instead of me using
all right don't go that way all right
instead of using
um
my little containment what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to be setting traps
all throughout circus smash his way
through there
you're gonna be setting traps around
this area right because it's more
important at this stage that we just
stop him
well we gotta kill him and we got to
kill him here we this is our last stand
and the monster has to come here there
is I'm not sure exactly what the current
sort of uh
scaring Birds he's coming current
situation is but
it definitely was previously you know
the a timer will if the monster doesn't
come engage us in a fight or engage
power relay then a timer will start at
the end of the timer
so the monster has to come in here and
destroy this power relay and then that's
only the first stage it's after the
power relay is destroyed the monster has
to then maybe kill scientists I think
here Bart Birds up ahead it's really
possible he's going to come from the
upper right he's right over there
here he is he should get stuck in a trap
up there going around there but
that I think is going to come back
around this side
uh because he didn't you can smash
through that oh I found him
oh he got caught my
mud he did hurt me though
oh God
yikes
okay he will try to smash me
he loves that leap smash he does
avoid rocks another good thing about the
Trent gun that Chris has is uh it makes
him slower which includes all his moves
so it'll make it a lot easier for you to
someone Dodge
ship
nope I am yes all right nice that was
good that was great cloaking all right
Daisy is gonna now go for that oh I'm in
bad shape I'm in a bad River dogs I need
help all right you're in trouble you
guys are revised so hopefully the
support will be able to come over here
and get me I'm gonna trap it all of you
go
so you need a decoy basically yeah to
get him to stay away because he knows
that we're gonna try to go after him so
what I'm trying to do is
all right are you getting revived yep
I'm good I'm back up I mean let's be
realistic here this is a boss fight it's
not meant to be easy he's not meant to
be taken down easily it takes all of us
together I got him in a few harpoons
there
he's down to two three bars health so
we're getting there we're doing good
we're doing good
I am now staying up out of the fight
because this actually has a way long
range on it that I I didn't think it was
quite this long 60 meters
I looked that up
all right so just keep hammering keep
hammering him with
all right he's in trouble
he's trying to take the power relay
oh yeah no we're we got this
keep healing me Waters
look at him I got him in uh Harpoon
right there look how annoying it is it's
so annoying he's so annoyed
you can put them at the top of places
too and it's really annoying for him
because he's going to run away but now
the timer's up there see there in the
top left yeah that's just a bad move
hopefully he might not know
um again pursue don't pursue just stay
back here as it is the alpha he might
not be aware Daisy we're cool over here
I can hear him
he's probably gonna try to go he might
try to come in another way Shields by
eating but I think it's better for us to
just hold the fort here we've got plenty
we are all pretty much full health uh we
don't we don't have a lot of
incapacitation strikes against us you
can see here on the assault there's that
one in cap strike on the health bar it's
a white block at the end of his green
bar that means he's been down once and
uh I think I see him
oh yeah there he is
uncatchy didn't even eat that much
oh [__]
he's so angry
oh yeah
you're dead nice work get dead boom
um that's great
that's how it's done